did you ever think there actually was a
dragon when you're a kid absolutely kid
are you talking about the airplane story
yeah well I mean yeah I'm gonna pose
like I was 13 years old you're talking
about stress yeah
well I mean if you must know I mean it's
a true story wasn't Anna folks at home I
was telling you that when I was 13 years
old and we have a news story that we
were gonna cover and I wasn't sure if we
should and it's about how they're making
airplanes they're putting more seats on
airplanes and the way they're cutting
spaces in the bathrooms and I was
concerned like where you know I and I
thought about where where am I gonna go
to jack off cuz I get you know I get I
get nervous on flights and stuff and a
lot of people do it I don't know but
when I was 13 I
yeah I went in there and I did that and
some lady walked in on me and I and she
was like two seats over and you just had
to stare you know just staring at me and
disgust for like five hours straight was
a long flight you sure you want me to
talk about I mean you really want me to
there's a different story
but anyway forget about that but what is
it they're making this thing smaller
they're too [ __ ] small for me when
nine wasn't a big [ __ ] fat guy when I
fly I don't want to look keV up wide
seats
short seats reclining seats how much
booze they're gonna give me what food
I'm gonna when I fly three things Arnold
will the plane take off wanted well it's
up in the air will its failure
and when it comes down is it coming down
where they said it would come down oh I
want to know
get on aeroplanes yeah
the language the language of Airlines
planes are never late Dulce the delayed
you get all the but one day the tape and
as always you see there's always these
words that these words are very
important a psychological wording you
get on an airplane sitting on the runway
ready to take off that's when the
hostess always tells you about the
things that can go wrong with the plane
they never tell you that when you're
buying the ticket today they never say
the wings could fall out or oxygen will
fail that they wait until you're sitting
that not only you're sitting there but
you're strapped you strapped into this
bunny thing and then under the guise of
talking about the doors they're giving
you a blessing
[Music]
use words of BA if by chance as if by
chance the pressurization of the cabin
drops oxygen will be provided that's
bloody nice of them is they've got you
up to 35,000 feet they're about to
asphyxiate you know we'll give you
sausage that's all oxygen will be
provided if an oxygen mask drops down in
front of you please place it over your
nose and mouth and breathe that's the
only part of your body you can breathe
you're not gonna stick it on your lot
and breathe normally normally can you
see yourself 35,000 feet and these
things drop out of the room like use
contraceptive
then you're gonna go oh look at that oh
that's interesting the pressurization of
the cabin must have dropped they're
biting us good oxygen Oh interesting is
it yes crap let me tell you if you're
sitting there at 35,000 feet and those
things drop down in front of you the
first thing that happens is your anal
nerve goes
[Applause]
I'm a jumbo jet that is 500 anal nurse
quicker the thing you get that thing
over your nose
[Music]
words like emergency landing have you
come across that emergency landing
emergency landing this clever wording
it's an emergency but it's a landing
they've got you down we're pros it's
emergency we've seen you through we've
got you down I don't have to worry about
urgency somebody says emergency to me
crash emergency landing hit some wall
bang bump into we're about to make an
emergency landing on the side of this
mountain
lovely things like make sure you do a
safety belt is fastened you see yourself
going through all this the plane is
coming in your table is filled seat is
in an upright position make sure that
all the property and glassing if you
give to the hostess would you take my
glass
take your teeth out they don't say take
your false teeth out they say take your
teeth
there were spoons going
place a pillow on your lap and place
your head on the lap you see that see
them come into the side of the mop with
your head on your lap that's so you can
kiss your ass good-bye
[Music]
brace yourself brace
what did you do when you hit the mom I
braced myself afraid do you know that an
aeroplane after 18 hours flying is just
filled with vomit defecation and farts
that's all it is it hits the side of a
mom
that's why nobody'll go new here for
days
if have you heard if in the unlikely
event of us having to put down on water
there's a double doubt there isn't it
unlikely put the truth it if unlikely
put down on water put down put down
leaves foot down
thistle down puts down feathers put down
jumbo jets have you seen one it's as big
as this stage overpriced say if I took
this fader up to 35,000 feet and dropped
it it would not put down
Barry itself from the bloody ground
infinitely unlikely event was having to
put down on water you will find your
lifejacket under your seat and then they
show you how to put it on place it over
your head you take two ribbons and
secretin body once tighten the bow on
the left-hand side let me do it
you see yourself pulled out of the sky
at 900 miles an hour
you put down in the Indian Ocean you see
in the Indian Ocean it's enormous
it's black and nasty and enormous it's
got waves huge gigantic waves following
each other all around have you look at
your safety card honey you have landed
in the Indian Ocean your captain has
managed to find a flat piece
your plane is flat all little blue waves
all around at all pretty
the yellow slides coming out of the side
of the airplane people doing the dingey
with a belt and children say mommy we're
going camping and email you see pictures
of the people leaving the airplane
[Music]
when the holsters was saying thank you
for flying me one thing you never see in
all that is little black fins do you you
never look at those pictures and those
little black fins all floating around in
there you get an aeroplane and you're
looking at the safety card and it has
black fins on it I have been there
before you that's what I do on
aeroplanes now I get the safety cards
and I draw in little black
and I get a reading can kind of put
little bits of red in it and for your
added safety while you're in the Indian
Ocean they give you a whistle
in the Indian Ocean
miles of nothing huge waves
rescue plane 40,000 feet
[Music]
you know the one thing I've always
always you hear about but any sort of
mishap with airplanes but one thing that
they always find the oldest thing to get
back is the flight recorder domain the
black box they always get the black box
back it's waterproof bomb-proof
fireproof it is totally indestructible
now why don't they put wings on it you
had though you had a pretty serious
incident flying into Boston oh that's an
accident yep I got into an accident on
the plane
it was the delayed a delayed scare
because we didn't realize that we were
in an accident
until until we said it out loud like we
knew something happened like we we we
knew we were coming in weird because the
plane called a tailwind so a piece of
the plane shifted down so you know
naturally we're on a plane we know
what's normal what's not dishes dishes
started flying I was like that's not
that don't normally happen but you know
you know we still cool we have a good
conversation we land the front hits the
back hits and you hear boom boom and we
all with each other and there was a
shock and I yelled out
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
we are not in the air on the tarmac like
you can hear like the train track he
turned into the most dramatic people it
stopped and the doors open
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
I'll tell you this story about one time
that I thought I was gonna die I think
it's the only time where I thought why
wouldn't this be when I died I was on a
plane I've been on a lot of planes and a
lot of shitty weather and stuff but this
[ __ ] was [ __ ] up I was in Indianapolis
on a plane waiting to take off and we're
sitting there and the pilot comes on and
he says I have folks the fuel gauge is
broken so were waiting for maintenance
so we wait about 20 minutes and he comes
back on folks the fuel gauge is still
broken but we're gonna go anyway and we
know how much you feel we have when we
feel confident it'll be okay so we're
gonna go I'm thinking okay well he's a
pilot I'm sure he's going by some manual
that says you know the fuel gauge brakes
call maintenance if they're not there in
20 minutes
[ __ ] it fuel gauges are overrated just
go you're fine just top it off and
remember what happened so then we still
don't take off and the guy comes back on
folks we have another problem like
Warren Airport in New York won't give us
clearance to take off because the
weather has been bad they're
intermittently so we're gonna wait for
that so we wait 20 minutes then he goes
back on out folks
LaGuardia still hasn't given us
clearance but we're gonna go anyway
we're looking at the radar we think the
weather will be fine
so what we're gonna do is say that our
destination is Philadelphia
I'll get clearance to go there halfway
to Philadelphia will switch course to
LaGuardia Airport will be held in
Phoenix I swear to God he said this
first of all I'm pretty sure you're
supposed to be honest with the dude in
the tower like this dude the tower have
to go really you're gonna come on tell
me where you're going and why is he
telling us this [ __ ] I am I gonna have
to corroborate this lie if we get pulled
over by the sky police at some point in
the flight oh no we're totally gonna
Philly I got a brother there and we got
a thing in Philly but I'm still flying
with it because we're travelers on the
plate yeah I got a thing [ __ ] it I'm
immortal just go please yes go into
marginal weather with shoddy equipment
secretly I totally support this plan so
we take off we get above where we are
right now and it's just a black
[ __ ] of a cloud it's just like
The Wizard of Oz is just there's trees
throwing apples at us that's crazy it's
just horrible and we get the whole
flight and we're making these circles
and me and the guy next to me are both
listening to the tower you know how you
can plug in your seats sometimes and you
can listen to the tower talk to the area
airplanes and we keep hearing our guy
trying to get clearance to land from
LaGuardia ah this is Delta 288
requesting clearance to land that's a
negative 288 low visibility she's
minutes go by is Delta 288 we would
really like clearance to land yeah
that's a negative 288 but he was getting
annoyed and meanwhile we're just
circling and burning this vague
fuel we could just stop being an
airplane at any second and then we hear
this this is all true this is LaGuardia
Airport to all area airplanes we are
closed for the night zero visibility
not safe for landing please divert to
Philadelphia or Allentown Pennsylvania
or Boston we need to lay now we have no
fuel
we have no feel yet the land right now
interesting then there's a pause and
then we hear this well then clear to
land then 280 yeah that's how he said
like dude no one can see okay but just I
guess all the dumb decisions you made
today have made this a good one just
take a shot I'm going home just [ __ ]
turn the lights off after you crash I
don't give a [ __ ] frankly by the way
you're not supposed to be here you
[ __ ] liar you say you're going to
Philly so as soon as we get clearance we
just maybe start bulleting we're either
flying desperately towards the ground or
falling I don't know that there's a
difference we come out of the clouds and
there's the [ __ ] earth right [ __ ]
there it's right there that's what low
visibility means
we come out of the clouds no [ __ ] it's
like Jesus and the plains is pure and
you can feel the plane go oh [ __ ] I
can't do that what are you nuts
and we go burn and veer over the highway
I swear to God I saw people in their
cars go what the foot and we hit the
runway like sideways and the pilot comes
back on all true I swear to God he's
totally out of brothers okay welcome to
Party Airport New York City you may turn
on your cell phones now and you may call
your loved ones he said that he said you
may call your loved ones and everybody
on the plane was crying and rocking back
and forth just sobbing calling their
husbands and their wives I'm divorced
what am I gonna hi remember you hate me
well I almost died and I got in a cab
and the cab driver goes that was a very
bad lending how did you know that was
means like that's the only plane to land
in four hours
we all watched the drivers we said that
are going to die dude I gotta be honest
I hate how scared I'm getting as I get
older I'm developing all these new fears
like I have a fear of flying now I never
had a fear of it it's not straight
across the board flying I don't like
small planes all of a sudden I just
don't like them it has nothing to do
with the plane I believe in the planes
okay I just don't believe in the pilots
alright cuz you know why I don't think
the airline does either which is why
that dude is flying that little plane
the airline was basically a I will give
you like 28 people fly them up your land
you bring another 28 back we'll let you
do this for do this for wild we don't
get any complaints no up and down up and
down
nope none of that [ __ ] but we'll be up
to 35 people then one day you'll be in a
Jet Blue we're going a little faster
right
big planes you're getting the [ __ ]
pilot that knows what he's doing
probably fought in a war used to getting
shot at you can't bring this bus in it's
a joke right a bunch of people whining
in the bank me headphones don't work he
doesn't give a [ __ ] right
he's up there sleeping he's trying to
make something happen he's so goddamn
bored that's a setup there right so one
time I'm flying into Albany New York
okay
a city that nobody really goes to so I'm
on a smaller plane and everything's
going great all of a sudden out of
nowhere we hit this turbulence and it
stops and everybody looks around like
laughing nervously like oh all of a
sudden it comes back with a vengeance
you can literally hear like the metal
the planes made out like all of a sudden
this dude like three rows back starts
making like these [ __ ] noises like
look look
[Applause]
I'm not gonna lie I have never been so
[ __ ] scared in my entire life who
that noise is acceptable out of a female
or a child the turn around and see a 37
year old mustachioed male go
look the hair was standing up on my arms
I'm praying to a higher power I don't
even believe in this [ __ ] I just wish I
had the balls to turn around be like
dude but you shut the [ __ ] up Jesus
Christ be a man push it down push it
down deny your feelings act like you
have answers to some man [ __ ] right now
who's the man [ __ ]
you know you think I'm not up here
thinking I am
well how does that help us for me to
join you and turn this fuselage into a
haunted house you know
your kills fee what absolutely kills me
is some woman is gonna fall in love with
this guy marry him and make half [ __ ]
kitsch
and you know what we become weaker as a
species
freedo
[Applause]
and you get on the plane pilot of course
always has to come on the PA system this
guy's so excited about being a pilot he
can't even stand himself well I'm going
to take it up to about twenty thousand
and I'm gonna make a left by Pittsburgh
and I'm gonna make it right by Chicago
then I'm gonna bring it down to fifteen
thousand the whole route all this moves
we're in the back going yeah fine that's
all you know do whatever the hell you
got to do I don't know
end up where it says on the ticket
really
do I bother him with what I'm doing
knocking on the cockpit door I'm having
the peanuts now
yeah that's what we're doing back here
so I keep you posted
I'm not gonna have them all now I'm just
gonna have a few I don't want to finish
it because it's such a big bag
then the stewardesses have to come out
they have to do their little emergency
equipment show you know that thing they
do one of them reads it the other one
acts it out hey we have seatbelts and
oxygen man's things for you to use they
show you how to use a seatbelt in case
you haven't been in a car since 1965 oh
you lift up on the buckle oh I was
trying to break the metal apart I
thought that's how it works I was gonna
try and tear the fabric part of the belt
I thought if I could just get it started
then they always point out the emergency
exits always with that very vague point
though isn't it
where that where the hell with these
places B which is say planes at a 90
degree degree angle your hair's on fire
you're looking for this
how do you think you're gonna do there
she's thinking I'm getting out before
you're getting out you're dead you're
dead I'm gonna then they always have to
close that first class curtain to and
they always give you that little look
maybe if you would work a little harder
I wouldn't have to do this
[Applause]
it's all tiny world on the airplane
isn't it as always that little tiny
table there a tiny computer and was in
little crab see tiny food tiny utensils
tiny liquor bottles tiny bathroom tiny
sink tiny mirror tiny faucets so he's a
small problem gonna be a slight delay
we're gonna be a little late I always go
in the airplane bathroom even if I don't
have to go I got to go in there it's
nice it's like your own little apartment
on the plane isn't it go in there lock
the door the life comes on after a
second second little surprise party but
I know he's impressed with the amount of
equipment that they have in that place I
mean it's a little but they got the
tissues towels closets compartments tiny
slot for used razor blades they always
have that who is shaving on the plane
and shaving so much they're using up
razor blades is this what's happening
what is the Wolfman flying in ever
question who could shave that much I
flew here the first class people just
they can just get on whenever they want
I've always hated that first class
people board at your leisure take your
tank first class people
coach people the weights it's it's cuz
my little piggies
so you do get on the first class people
they're already sitting there they're
all sprawl that in their big fitting use
their bathrooms the bathrooms up front
are for our first-class passengers the
coach bathrooms are located at Newark
Airport concourse C concourse C ladies
and gentlemen so when you do board the
first-class people they're sitting there
a lot of them are working as your
boarding they have computers out with
calculators but looking up and you're
like hey we're making money right now
right now we're making money go get in
the back close that curtain not a want
to sing
even in my peripheral snapping snapping
shot so neither of us they gotta cover
us up with a tarp you go in the back
everybody has coloring books you're in
the middle and there's nine of us and
you're in the middle and we have all the
armrests so you gotta sit like this you
gotta figure out a way to eat your snack
while your boys are touching
you gotta learn how to twist them in a
plastic utensil
[Applause]
like to see laying back waiting back
except for one thing all the good meals
run out you know you're poking their
head off from road 199 the flight
attendants of this big you can hear the
big meals getting snagged we have a
turkey sandwich chicken quesadilla and
cold fish head I'm just
[Music]
one or what I'm good
[Music]
so when they get to the back of the
plane they have to do that flight
attendant psychology game pretend like
the good stuff never even existed then
never even once would you like a nice
cold fish head they're frozen solid
frozen head of fish the eyeballs in
there and the skeletons coming out it
comes with a turnip and a spork I was
with you'd had one of them look we
should have punished but I admire flight
attendants again I really do they put up
with a lot of garbage from people have
you ever been sitting in your seat and
you see somebody trying to fit something
the overhead wrap that you know ain't
going in there like in a million years
got like a mattress and a lamp look what
kind of perception problems this guy had
and the flight attendants are always
nice I just run up and act like it might
maybe fed you know oh I don't know if
that's gonna get up there we can check
it for you get more on I know that's
what they want to say I would last about
eight seconds at that job I just get up
there does that look like it's gonna fit
this much room you have a dead yeah
are you okay you don't see all these
people gin buck waiting and you don't
see anything
[Music]
[Applause]
oh this is your world it's all about you
you let us know when you're all set
captain you plan it
[Applause]
and I feel bad for the gate agents
because they try to get the boarding
process to run smoothly but no one will
listen to them don't blame them they try
they get on the intercom ladies and
gentlemen we're about to begin boarding
if we can ask for your cooperation would
you all please remain seated until your
Row has been called everyone please
please remain seated everyone please
back away from the gate please back away
from the gate somehow by the time that
comes out the speakers it must sound
like everybody up and rush the door
everyone immediately try to squish your
fat butt simultaneously in the small
gate dorm area hurry
push and shove everyone pushing shoving
do whatever you do to get on board
[Laughter]
even bears to be human
[Laughter]
[Applause]
human beings I'm sure you've been at
airports with the moving sidewalks
you know the whole stand right walk left
concept for some people unlearn a boat
you ain't getting it in no matter how
much stimuli you offer
I've been on there I don't understand
how people don't see that that's the
system there's a big yellow dotted line
going down the middle and it's tense on
every three feet on the sidewalk Stan
Stan Stan Stan walk walk walk on the
handrail stance and walk walk with your
stand walk pictures of people standing
what these book means together in a park
and you go riding that left hand
[Applause]
watching clothes because they're the
ones at the end of the movie sidewalk